We should not exaggerate at over Sweden
we are also and more and more
heterogeneous society.
But uh,
if American economists,
politicians,
once you look around to see how how
other countries have fared and they've
met the same global environment as
America has met,
then there might be some things to pick
up.
And we have been subject not to the
same,
but to more intense competitive
pressures from new emerging economies.
We have not done your China,
Vietnam,
India as new competitors compared to
what was there 15 or 20 years ago.
We also have next door Poland,
the Baltic republics,
Russia with a highly educated workforce
with very,
very low wages,
perhaps 10% of the wages paid in my
country and the Rsa one hour away from
us.
So we have faced more intense
globalization
then the American economy and facing
more or less the same pressures.
We have increased employment,
increased rate wages,
also for blue collar workers were
maintained strong support for open
borders and we've been able to develop
our society.
Whereas in the United States,
people are afraid of foreign
competition.
Real wages have declined.
Employment has not risen very much.
And I think to blame technological
change and globalization in the United
States cannot be true if the same
elements have led to a completely
different outcome in a country like
mine.
But my country is a small open economy
with a very high level of education and
a sophisticated social model.
I do not say that what we do can be
transformed into an new American
modeling in 10 minutes.
But,
uh,
please have a look and see what there is
the pickup of,
uh,
of inspiration from a model that isn't
very different but has stood the test of
globalization much better than the
American model.
We continue to intensify.
It will affect more areas.
It will include more countries and in
each country it will include more and
more sectors.
And uh,
together with technological change,
which I believe is an underestimated
force behind the changes we have seen
and we are seeing together,
they will continue to transform our
countries and the global economy.
Globalization to me,
it means not only financial markets,
not only trade in products like cars,
it also means culture,
news,
perception of the world,
and,
uh,
all kinds of other things.
Maybe we should call it under the label
that the world is shrinking.
Borders mean less.
The Internet means that we can
communicate more and more people speak a
language where they can communicate with
people in other parts of the,
of,
of the planet.
All these things together work to shrink
distances.
And that is a much,
much larger,
much,
much wider concept and only interest
rates,
shares and uh,
and physical goods moving around.
Yeah.